Ils m'ont eu !
Les conspirationnistes !
J'me barre !
Ça y'est une fois de plus y'a un truc qui m'a bouffé le cerveau et je n'arrive plus à dormir.
Et une fois de plus j'fais une vidéo pour vous en parler
pour me sentir moins seul dans ma détresse.
Ça fait longtemps en plus qu'on n'a pas fait une vidéo euh...
Conspirations, théories du complot tout ça
Franchement, je pense qu ça va être la meilleure de toutes parce que
y'a un tel mystère autour que c'est génial
Autant les gens qui croient en la Terre plate je trouve ça CON
car t'as juste à envoyer un putain de satellite en l'air pour comprendre que c'est faux
Autant là...
[bruit d’ornithorynque étouffé]
J'adore !
Connaissez-vous les pyramides?
Y'en a dans dans pleins de pays
Certaines sont vieilles de plusieurs milliers d'années
Les plus connues sont sur le plateau de Gizeh, en Égypte.
Où on peut trouver les pyramides de Khéops
la plus grande,
celle de Khephren
et celle de Mykerinos
Alors, avant de commencer à parler des pyramides
de pourquoi elles attisent la curiosité de beaucoup beaucoup de scientifiques
ET LA MIENNE
le bon con de Squeezie
C'est très mystérieux ce qu'il y a autour des pyramides
On ne sait toujours pas comment elles ont été construites à l'époque
On a des théories
Mais on n'a jamais mis en pratique la théorie
C'est-à-dire que on pense qu'ils ont fait comme ça mais on n'a jamais essayé de le faire nous
De la même manière
Ce qui fait que tout ça, c'est des théories
Y'a des spéculations autour de certaines théories plus que d'autre
mais c'est ça qui fait le CHARME des pyramides
C'est ce putain de mystère qu'il y a
Sauf que y'a des faits qu'on peut constater en allant voir les pyramides
Qui remettent en question certaines choses qu'on a affirmées
Qui sont peut_être pas vraies
Peut-être qu'on s'est trompés
J'vais peut-être faire des erreurs dans ce que je dis
J'vais peut-être dire des trucs où j'suis un petit peu à côté de la PLAQUE
Mais ne m'en voulez pas, voilà
J'veux juste parler d'un sujet que... qui me fascine
et je vais essayer de dire le moins de conneries possible
Et vous savez quoi?
Si vous voulez me corriger sur certains trucs ou plutôt apporter des précisions
N'hésitez pas... dans les commentaires
Je veux que cet espace commentaire
soit le MEILLEUR DE TOUT YOUTUBE
Maintenant que ceci est dit:
Commençons!
Les pyramides sont des tombeaux pour les pharaons
Ça, je pense que vous le savez
la plus grande pyramide serait le tombeau de Khéops
Pourquoi je dis Khéops en criant? je ne sais pas
mais j'suis éxcité de vous en parler
La grande pyramide de Khéops
Très vieille d'environ 4 500 ans
Elle est faite de plus de deux MILLIONS de blocs de pierre
Différents, de formes et de tailles différentes
Et vous allez voir dans quelques instants que ça a pas du tout été fait à l'arache
Que tout était parfaitement
Calculé
D'après la plupart des égyptologues
Elle aurait été construite en vingt ans
Pourquoi vingt ans et pas plus?
parce que c'est la durée euh... du règne de Khéops
Et si c'est vraiment son tombeau
Eh bien la construction
n'aurait pas pus durer plus longtemps que son règne
20 ans pour empiler 2 millions de blocs de pierres
pesant chacun entre 2 et 10 tonnes
C'est bon pour vous ?
Alors y'a des stats' très connues qui montrent que si c'était vraiment le cas,
si ça avait vraiment été fait en 20 ans
à raison de 12 heures de travaille par jour
Tout les jours de l'année
ça représenterai un bloc extrait taillé et mis à sa place toutes les 2 minutes 30
(Mouais)
Peut être ! Peut être qu'ils étaient vraiment trop malins
Et c'est ça qui est génial, c'est qu'autour des pyramides y'a des mystères
Parce qu'on se dit "Putain mais alors comment ils ont fait ! Les mecs étaient en slip !"
*expiration d'asthmatique*
Bon revenons à nos cailloux là,
y'a 2 millions de blocs et il a bien fallu les trouver quelque part ces blocs
et ils sont pas allés les chercher autour de la pyramide
ils sont allés les chercher dans des cavernes de granit
à des centaines de kilomètre au sud de la pyramide
C'est à dire qu'ils allaient extraire les pierres là-bas
et qu'ils les transportées sur plusieurs centaines de kilomètres
et ils ne connaissaient pas la roue
Alors y'a plusieurs théories sur la façon dont ils ont transporté ces énormes
blocs de pierres sur des centaines de kilomètre
la première (montre?) qu'ils auraient utilisé un traîneau de halage en bois
qu'ils fessaient glissé sur le sol à l'aide de corde en chanvre
fallait donc aménager des voies sur de très grande distance
Et surtout une fois arrivé vers la pyramide
construire un chemin pour amener les pierres en haut de cette dernière
Sauf qu'il y'a une autre théorie qui vient contrer cette théorie là
en montrant que les chemins permettant d'acheminer les pierres vers le haut de la pyramides
se seraient affaissés peu à peu à cause du poids des pierres
et donc ils auraient fallu les reconstruire pas mal de fois
mais tellement de fois sur vingt ans que ça auraient demandé autant d'effort
de construire les chemins que de construire la pyramide
le tout toujours en vingt ans
donc ça fait beaucoup de chose à faire quand même en vingt ans putain
aujourd'hui on pense que leurs outils étaient les suivants:
Un burin de cuivre, un maillet de pierre et des cordes
ils auraient fait ce truc là
avec ces outils là
quand nous avec les outils, les technologies d'aujourd'hui
il nous faudrait 25 ans pour la construire et le travail
serait beaucoup moins précis que ce que eux ont fait ?
Pourquoi pas ! C'est peut être beau casse tête,
peut être qu'ils avaient vraiment que ces outils là
Et qu'ils étaient juste beaucoup plus malins que nous
De toutes manières, gardez en tête que toute théorie n'est prouvée
Mais qu'il y'a juste des théories qui paraissent
plus vraies que d'autres. Mais rien n'est prouvé
donc on peut tout imaginer c'est pour ça que j'adore les pyramides
Alors y'a aussi des sites autours des trois pyramides où
...
*bisous*
*smack*
...
(explications en commentaire svp)
qui sont par exemple des sanctuaires qui sont fait de mur
sauf que les méthodes utilisées pour faire ces murs
sont différentes des notres
La manière la plus simple de faire un mur aujourd'hui
en fait c'est de faire des pierres de la même taille,
De les mettre les unes sur les autres
Et de les fixer avec du ciment
A l'époque,  ils n'ont pas du tout fait ça !
Ils ont découpé des pierres, avec des formes qui ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
et pourtant elles s'emboîtent PAR-FAI-TE-MENT
C'est une précision, c'est chirurgicale
et il n'y a pas de ciment entre les pierres
pourtant, on ne même pas y passer une feuille de papier
C'est quand même INCROYABLE !
NAN IL Y A QUE MOI QUI TROUVE ÇA INCROYABLE !?
Bah, tout les maçons qui là, regardent la vidéo avoués que c'est quand même INCROYABLE !
*rire* J'essaie de me rassurer
On l'a vue la pyramide a été construite à base de 2 millions de blocs de formes et de tailles différentes
et le fait que se soit hétérogène ça permet, tout simplement à la pyramide de résister aux séismes
Elle a traversé des millers d'années, des séismes elle en a connus
et pourtant elle est encore LÀ !
En état, magnifique par rapport à son ancienneté
pourtant les égyptologues et historiens
nous disent que les égyptiens ne connaissaient pas
l'anti-sismie (sismique)
c'est-à-dire cette science qui permet de résister
aux séismes, aux tremblements de terres,
aux mouvements des plaques tectoniques.
COMMENT ILS ONT FAIT ALORS ?!
Autres points dans ces fameux lieux
qui y'a autour des pyramides
On trouve des pierres
dans lesquels y'a des coupes vraiment
nettes.
Qu'on arrive aujourd'hui à faire avec nos outils
modernes.
Donc des scies qui tournent extrêmement vite
qui sont extrêmement solides etc...
Bon je connais pas trop le taillage de pierre
mais voilà je sais qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à faire des
coupes assez nettes dans des pierres très très solides.
Mais à l'époque je le rappelle ils avaient ÇA !
*rire*
Comment ont-ils fait pour faire des coupures si NETTES
dans des roches si DENSES ?
Et surtout dans des quantités pareilles alors qu'ils n'avaient
qu'un maillet de pierre et un burin.
Alors encore une fois peut être que c'était leurs outils mais
qu'ils avaient quand même des techniques particulières
pour réussir à couper de cette manière là, la pierre.
Ou alors ils avaient d'autres outils dont ont n'a pas retrouvés de traces
et qu'ils leur permettaient de faire ça.
Mais on ne sait pas !
Autre chose aussi à propos de ces outils c'est que la pyramide
est orienté presque PAR-FAITEMENT vers le Nord
vers le pôle magnétique Nord.
Mais à l'époque ils avaient pas de (?/compas), ils avaient pas de boussole
pour mesurer, pour voir où était le Nord, l'Ouest, l'Est et le Sud.
Et pourtant elle est décalée que de 5 centièmes de degrés
par rapport au Nord parfait.
Pour vous donner un ordre d'idée, l'observatoire de Paris
qui a été construit au 17 siècle, lui est décalé de
25 centièmes de degrés par rapport au Nord.
Alors qu'on est des milliers d'années plus tard
On arrive pas à faire aussi bien qu'eux.
C'est ça qui est fou.
BON OK Lucas on a compris la construction c'est
trop bizarre tout ces blocs, tout ces trucs
mais peut être qu'ils l'ont fait !
Peut être qu'ils ont tout simplement vraiment transportés tout ça
qu'ils ont vraiment réussis à tailler tout ça avec leur burin
parce qu'ils étaient extrêmement nombreux !
Avec des architectes incroyables, avec des méthodes incroyables
avec une rigueur exceptionelle
et peut être qu'ils ont vraiment réussis cette exploit en fait.
Alors la on est juste sur la théorie de la construction
qui est la théorie principale de savoir comment ils ont fait ?
Y'a des trucs quand même bien plus bizarres que ça
Premièrement la grande pyramide du Gizeh indiquerait
les équinoxes.
Les équinoxes, c'est le moment de l'année où le Soleil
se trouve le plus à l'Est.
En fait les phases de la pyramide serait légèrement  courbées
vers l'intérieur et c'est ce qui permet de créer une ombre quand on est en jour d'équinoxe
Ce qui est fou avec ça, c'est que c'est encore plus dur de faire les pyramides
si les faces sont légèrement creusées vers l'intérieur.
Les théories montrent qu'en faite y'avait un revêtement sur la pyramide qui s'est effondré,
et qu'avec le temps, les murs se sont tout simplement tassés vers l'intérieur,
attirés vers l'intérieur de la pyramide.
Ce qui aurait créer ces petits angles sur les parois,
et que le fait que ça crée une ombre uniquement le jour de l'année où le Soleil est le plus à l'Est
serait un pur HASARD.
*moment de réflexion de la part de Lucas*
Peut être !
*rire*
En vrai peut-être on n'en sait rien c'est ça qui est bien
c'est que tout est possible et imaginable.
Autre truc très étrange, c'est la théorie de la corrélation d'Orion.
Certains égyptologues se sont mis d'accord à dire que c'est pas le fruit du hasard
que y'aurait une corrélation entre l'emplacement vu du ciel, du site des pyramides du Gizeh,
et les étoiles de la constellation d'Orion.
Et ça c'est le début d'une réflexion qui montre que
cette civilisation avait une connaissance incroyable des astres.
Le site du Gizeh serait tout simplement une horloge astronomique,
permettant de savoir la position de la Terre au cours d'un cycle de presque 26 000 ans.
Et que la tête de Sphinx dont on a pas encore parlé
qui se trouve sur le site du Gizeh,
aurait quelque chose à voir avec tout ça.
La fameuse tête de Sphinx dont qui a perdu sa crinière.
Je sais plus le nom voilà, y'a pleins de mots qui m'échappent.
Mais vous comprenez grâce aux images, merci Clément (le monteur).
N’aurait pas été construit en même temps que la grande pyramide du Gizeh
elle aurait été construite plusieurs milliers d'années avant.
Le regard de la tête de Sphinx serait l'aiguille, de cette horloge.
Et les points de repères serait la constellation du Taureau,
du Lion, du Scorpion et du Verseau.
On voit que sur le Sphinx y'a un caillou qui ressort.
On appelle ça "le coeur du Sphinx".
En arabe "Al qalb al assad"
J'espère bien dire, désolé j'suis un babtou fragile je sais pas parler arabe.
Et il se trouve que c'est aussi le nom qu'ils donnaient à l'étoile la plus brillante de la constellation
du Taureau.
Une étoile qu'un appelle aujourd'hui "Regulus"
Quand on prends le regard du Sphinx comme indicateur et comme référence dans le cycle :
"l'étoile la plus brillante de la constellation du Lion"
on obtient donc un cycle de 26000 années
Alors peut-être que c'est tout simplement le fruit du hasard
et qu'on s'imagine des choses
ou peut-être que, à l'époque,
lors de la construction de ces énormes édifices
ils avaient une connaissance parfaite des astres
et c'était totalement voulu
Mais alors, pourquoi vouloir repérer la position de la terre sur un cycle de 26000 ans?
Ca, c'est une question à laquelle on ne sait pas répondre
Là on part dans les grosses théories du complot
mais y'a des théories qui montrent qu'en fait tous les 26000 ans
les pôles magnétiques de la terre s'inverseraient
ce qui ferait qu'on ne serait plus protégé par l'atmosphère pendant un certain temps
et ce qui anéantirait toute forme de vie à la surface de la Terre
et en gros, la terre redémarrerait à zéro
Ainsi soit il, j'ai envie de vous dire, on sera déjà dead d'ici là
sauf si la fin du cycle c'est dans cinq ans
mais c'est pas le cas, je sais plus à combien on en est mais on est pas du tout aux 26000 ans
Autre chose intéressante, on a trouvé sur le Sphinx
des traces d'érosion liées à de l'eau
ce qui montre qu'un jour il aurait été enseveli sous l'eau
sauf que pour qu'il soit enseveli sous l'eau
il aurait fallu que le niveau des océans soit plus haut de 160 mètres
et la dernière fois qu'il a été aussi haut c'était il y a 700 000 ans
Est ce que le Sphinx aurait donc 700 000 ans?
ou est ce que pendant les  milliers d'années qui ont suivi sa construction
le climat était très différent et il y avait énormément de pluie?
Est ce que les pyramides auraient elles aussi 700 000 ans?
Est ce que les Egyptiens auraient donc en fait non pas construit la pyramide en 20 ans
mais essayé de faire un revêtement de cette dernière pour l'entretenir?
On ne sait pas, et c'est beaucoup de questions auxquelles on n'a pas de réponses
le cerveau n'aime pas l'inconnu
d'ailleurs la paréidolie, la dernière fois on a vu ça, notre cerveau n'aime pas l'inconnu
et donc on veut tout le temps
trouver des explications à des choses
sauf que des fois on n'arrive pas à en trouver
mais on fait comme si on en avait trouvé
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur les pyramides de Gizeh
j'espère que ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à aimer si c'est le cas
(blblblblblb)
je trouve ça passionnant comme sujet,
il y a énormément de documentaires, énormément d'égyptologues qu'on a interviewés
d'architectes, d'historiens
beaucoup de gens vraiment bien plus compétents que moi
qui ont parlé à ce sujet
et c'est très intéressant de voir toutes leurs opinions
de voir toutes les théories émises
de voir comme ça les passionne
et comme il y a des gens qui bossent au moment où on se parle
en masse pour essayer de résoudre ces fameux mystères, de répondre à ces fameuses questions
je suis désolé si j'ai dit des bêtises, encore une fois,
je me suis beaucoup documenté et tout mais je reste un gros amateur
je mettrai quelques liens dans la description
si il y en a qui veulent se documenter un peu plus
et avoir plus d'infos sur ça
et je tenais à faire cette vidéo parce que
tous les gens qui ne valident pas les théories
validées en masse par beaucoup d'égyptologues
passent pour des fous,pour des illuminés
je crois qu'ils ont même un nom,les Pyramidos ou je sais pas quoi
Et en fait, ça montre juste que quand on n'est pas d'accord avec la théorie principale
on passe pour un fou mais quand cette théorie n'a pas été prouvée,
je vois pas en quoi tout ça c'est de la folie
en fait on peut tout imaginer, et c'est ça que je trouve passionnant
avec cette théorie là, et c'est pas pour moi de la théorie du complot
c'est de la théorie tout court
et c'est pour ça que je trouvais ça amusant d'en parler aujourd'hui en vidéo
Bref, je suis très curieux, hésitez pas à me donner des news du coup sur tout ça
moi aussi je me tiendrai informé et peut-être qu'on refera une vidéo
si ça se trouve dans des années où on aura découvert un peu plus de choses
En bref, est ce que ça a été construit par des gens comme nous
ou par des gens comme nous mais bien plus avancés
technologiquement parlant que nous, mais qui n'ont laissé aucune trace
Ou alors est-ce que ça a été construit par une civilisation extraterrestre
ou alors est ce que ça a été vraiment construit par des gens
qui avaient  les outils et les moyens qu'on pense qu'ils avaient
et qu'on a juste toujours pas trouvé avec quelles techniques ils ont réussi
on ne sait pas, et ça j'adore, c'est génial
qu'il y ait un gros doute sur ça, c'est trop bien quoi
on peut croire ce qu'on veut, et ça, j'adore
Je vous dis à bientôt, portez vous bien tchao les amis
Groos bisouus
(rire)